hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
dieses video hat drei themen und zwar
erstens ich war auf einer bühne zweitens
wieso mich fanpages gehärtet haben auf
install am und drittens ganz kurz dieser
kuchen tv castingshows aber will ich nur
ganz kurz thema normal ihr seht schon
eingeblendet ich war auf einer bühne
obwohl ich ein genieß kann normaler
leute sind auf einer bühne weil sie
singen können weil wie malen können weil
sie gut zocken können weil sie gute
videos machen ich war auf der bühne weil
ich einfach eine million abonnenten
erreicht habe er hat man sich auch
sparen können das stimmt luca also das
war übrigens im zuge der video days also
ich war der videodienst bühne falls sich
das noch nicht irgendwie erlebt habe ich
fange jetzt mal komplett am anfang an
und zwar hat nicht youtube damals vor
irgendwie 12 monaten gefragt luca
hedgehog weil du hast eine million
abonnenten erreicht letztes jahr dass
wir den goldenen play button auf der
bühne bereich und ich dachte mir ich
habe eigentlich gar keine richtigen fans
es macht wirklich überhaupt keinen sinn
jedenfalls an dem ich dann trotzdem
gegen überzeugt gekriegt dass ich meinen
button auf der vino bereich bekomme und
dann war ich hab meine hand und am t
shirt weil's mich juckt und die
verleihung war am freitagabend auf dem
video days und da wurden quasi erst also
die ausschnitte von allen leuten gezeigt
die eine million abonnenten innerhalb
der letzten zwölf monate erreicht habe
und ich fühle mich halt wirklich wieso
ein ganz normaler typ der einfach irgend
so einem scheiß ins internet stellt und
ein paar leute feiern und viele fans
nicht und ein paar leute mögen dich und
ein paar leute hassen mich und ich
dachte nur so hey okay wenn keiner
schreit das wäre schon echt und ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass einer irgendwie
ausrastet beim einem clip
inside ganz schön ab gegangen
also das war schon krass und dann ist
glaube ich als erster kräftig auf die
bühne gegangen hatte seinen play button
bekommen danach wurde ich um kelly
aufgerufen und kelly und ich haben uns
irgendwie als geist verkleidet fragt uns
sicher wie auf die idee gekommen sind
wir haben uns einfach gedacht ja oder
liegt mit tischdecke lass meine clown
und lasse damit auch die bühne laufen
aber seht selbst 2000 jahre später und
dann haben wir halt den umhang gefallen
gelassen
warum geht mir da so abwärts war so
krank alter das war für mich zu ich lass
diesen umhang fallen und alle rasten so
aus es war ihre handy macht er öfter so
moderation sachen und ich bin halt so
ein kleiner junge daneben und stand noch
nie auf einer bühne
deswegen war ich halt echt hart nervöse
hat also eine kleine rede gehalten es
nicht für den support bin dein herz ziel
vor sechs jahren waren eigentlich die
100 abonnenten
schon bei 1,5 ist einfach der wahnsinn
und dankeschön an alle meine zuschauer
und dann kam ich nervös und hab total
verkackt ich bin nervös
viele denken sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht so jahr hat die gal als ob seine
einzige sache war dir gesagt hat ich bin
nervös also ich habe mich dann schon
noch versucht zu bedanken also ich kann
das eigentlich immer wiederholen was
hätte schon gesagt hat ein großes danke
und bevor ich jetzt mehr schwarze lager
zurück aber ihr müsst euch das wirklich
so vorstellen ich habe mir wirklich
immer gedacht ja ob ich jetzt hier mein
zimmer stehen was zu euch rede oder ob
ich darauf auf einer bühne stehe und von
15.000 leuten was redet ist doch keinen
keinen unterschied so richtig aber dass
das war so irre ich bin überhaupt nicht
klargekommen den füßen haben gezittert
ich wusste nicht dass einen die füße
zittern können ich stand da quasi so
hallo kann nicht reagieren mit mir hat
wirklich alles gezittert ich übelst der
börse und vor allem wann hört sich da
irgendwie doppel ich hab dann dieses
mikrofon oben ab so dass ich bin der
böse und selbst das habe ich gar nicht
richtig hingekriegt zu sagen weil man ja
quasi hinter den boxen steht und
irgendwie erzählt man was man hört es
irgendwie doppelte lich bewegt ich habe
wieder schon die ganze zeit weil ich
wieder so ein teil ich will ich war auf
der bühne und ich habe total verschissen
aber es war witzig weil ich habe mir
gedacht ja die aufnahme habe ich jetzt
zugeschickt bekommen so dann war ihr
darüber einsatzzeit war das jahr war das
feuer support das zweite thema reden
wollte einige instagram fanpages haben
sich darüber beschwert dass ich an dem
samstag sie angelogen hätte und gesagt
hätte ich gehe noch autogramme aber dann
keine autogramme gegeben habe hier meine
story dazu das wissen die videos waren
haben freitag und am samstag also
zweitägig und am freitag am ersten tag
als ich ankam was irgendwie so 15 16
uhren ich bin sogar diesen umlauf der
arena glaubt das ist quasi sonnen
erhöhter weg um die arena rom unter köln
in einem quasi die zuschauer von unten
sehen die marine lange schreien läuft
oder sich etwas zu essen heute da
irgendwie sowas und da habe ich als sehr
viele leute schon gesehen haben
gekreischt
mehr langsam auf gekreische beim namen
gerufen ich bin da eine treppe nach
unten gegangen weil ich halt unbedingt
mit euch fotos machen wollten autogramme
geben wollte land haben security team
hat gesagt hätte ja bist du bescheuert
und gibt autogramme auf einer treppe die
stürzen sich der gleich alle runter wenn
dann noch mehr leute kommen und alles
ausgelassen das war eine halbe
massenpanik dann habe ich halt gesagt ja
freunde genießt jetzt mal die show ich
gehe da oben die mir was zu essen kommen
bisschen runter und dann liebe dich wenn
die video des vorbei sind vor der alle
autogramme die videos waren dann glaube
ich so um 18.19 uhr zu ende und ich war
verabredet zum essen um 20.30 und
bildern aber trotzdem noch mal mit seppl
also escape zockt und jona pischel nach
draußen gelaufen autogramme zu geben das
ganze habe ich dann zwei stunden lang
durchgezogen bis irgendwie 21 uhr und
ich bin quasi extra beiden ich mir noch
für euch die zeit genommen habe und vor
die arena gegangen bin was nicht mehr
teil der video days war sondern ich habe
mich einfach vor die abwehr mit euch
gestellt mit euch unterhalten fotos
gemacht videos gemacht us-botschaften
autogramme gegeben et cetera und
deswegen bin ich fast eine stunde zu
spät zu einem sehr wichtigen essen
gekommen alles quasi für euch und dann
am samstag einem zweiten tag war ja
quasi die autogrammstunden tag und
einfach nur damit ich diesen stress
nicht habe das nicht wegen einer
bestimmten uhrzeit irgendwo sein muss
weil ich immer zu spät bin unternehmer
leute traurig wäre weil sie an dem stand
nicht mehr drangekommen werden habe ich
halt direkt von anfang an gesagt ich
gebe keine autogrammstunde und hat quasi
alle abgesagt max einer autogrammstunde
war irgendwie so um 17 uhr und am
samstag sind wir dann um 15 uhr zu dem
hof stand gerannt wo wir wieder von us
raube von unglaublich vielen leuten von
euch verfolgt wurden wir sind zum
hausstand gerannt und haben dort dann
autogramme gibt vielleicht habe ich
davon sogar noch einen snack den ich
jetzt mal eben einblenden kann
da standen so unserer viele menschen von
euch und wir hätten das niemals auch nur
acht stunden geschafft alles davon
fällig zu machen also jeder wollte ja
dann irgendwie ein foto das auch
unterstützen oder eine grußbotschaft
noch ein video 9 für den freund uli
katzer deswegen habe ich kurz vor max
fotografischer gesagt ja auch freunde
ich gehe jetzt mit in die halle zu max
autogrammstunde gebe dort mit autogramm
also kommt da hin wenn ihr noch was
wollt und dem ist in der halle standen
fünf tische und an den tischen saßen
hier irgend welche leute da da da da und
ihr saßen max zusammen mit pixel wolf
glaube ich an dieser stelle beträgt
pixel wollte aber er stand dort zusammen
mit 345 kollegen oder so von sich
deswegen weil ganze tisch voll und max
us-dollar mit seiner freundin also
wirklich überhaupt keinen vorwurf an
irgendwen oder so weil die waren ja alle
auch angemeldet und waren daher
rechtmäßig nun das war halt der grund
wieso ich mich nicht mehr darzustellen
konnte also da war wirklich alles voll
ich hätte mich da irgendwie zwischen
fashion müssen und ich glaube das hätte
pixelig cool gefunden und max ist auch
nicht cool gefunden ich meine stellt
euch das vor da freut sich ein youtube
auf den autogrammstunden kommt eine
andere youtuber und kräftig damit zusagt
dann hätte ich gehe jetzt auch hier mit
autogramme weil ich das nicht alle
beschafft habe wäre ja auch nicht so
cool deswegen hab ich mir gedacht okay
ich stelle mich wenn die leute fertig
sind an dem tisch also wenn die sich
alle angestanden haben da hier die
sachen abgeholt haben von den youtube da
stelle ich mich danach hin und gibt
autogramme
aber ich bin ja dumm innerhalb von zwei
minuten war da wieder eine riesige
traube um mich rum und alle wollten
fotos und ich kann das wieder nicht mehr
raus nahm er die video days leute und
die security leute gesagt hat ist
eigentlich dumm du stehst jetzt von dem
in dem ausgang wo alle weglaufen und so
entweder einschätzt irgendwo zu oder du
gibt es keine autogramme oder wie auch
immer und dann habe ich gedacht ihr euch
doch ich mache hier vielmehr mit
kaputter als dass ich eben die leute
glücklich machen kann deswegen habe ich
gesagt ja freunde
ich hoffe dass jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
die nach hinten und dann bin ich quasi
nachdem alles vorbei war nochmal da
draußen gegangen wie das bildungszentrum
zusammenzufassen
ich habe jetzt mittlerweile fast zwei
millionen abonnenten auf youtube und das
ist seine enorme masse an menschen das
ist nicht mehr möglich ist dass ich
einfach sagen kann ob ich lauf hier rum
und gibt autogramme weil der welt
tagelang beschäftigt es tut mir leid ich
habe alles getan ich bin mit sicherheit
nicht irgendwie abgehauen sowie das
einige instagram fanseiten gepostet
haben oder ich hab euch auch nicht
verarschen oder so ich habe wirklich
alles versucht leider macht steht und
die leute die mit dem freitagabend noch
vor der arena stand business mir
wirklich für jeden zeit genommen habe
aber es tut mir leid dass diesmal nicht
geklappt hat die video days sind nicht
schuld keine schuld aber ich muss
einfach mal überlegen wie es in zukunft
hand habe sorry ich liebe euch trotzdem
alle thema nummer drei ks freak versus
kuchen tv mann mann mann ist das ein
kinderspiel dies noch immer nicht
mitbekommen haben
patrick hatten auftritt gegeben bei den
bio days hat playback irgendeinen song
gesungen und da sind zwei andere
youtuber talent einhörner auf die bühne
gestürmt und haben sich dort gegenseitig
gefegt und sie wollten marcel das mikro
aus der anreise und danach wieder nach
unten gegangen und was hat die [ __ ]
genannt
und das war die komplette story ich will
ja gar nicht viel zu sagen ich finde nur
irgendwie scheiße wie das ganze
irgendwie so hoch geschwappt ist
mittlerweile auch in den youtube trends
weil das dass jeder einfach wieder
darüber macht man muss deine meinung
dazu sagen sonst ist man kein youtuber
mehr deswegen hier ganz kurz meine
meinung ich kann beide seiten
nachvollziehen ich will mich nicht auf
einer seite positionieren ich muss
ehrlich gesagt zu geben kuchen tv kenne
ich nicht persönlich ich bin kein großer
fan von seinem content der hat mich auch
schon das ein oder andere mal hoch
genommen aber ich hab dem eigentlich nie
viel beachtung geschenkt und ich glaube
auch wenn ich einen auftritt auf der
bühne gehabt hätte und die welt auf die
bühne gegangen wäre ich eher der typ
gewesen
er ist lustig gefunden hätte ja aber ich
schenk sowas eigentlich nicht viel
beachtung im gegensatz dazu hat marcel
als auf der bühne war die beiden
[ __ ] genannt und danach irgendwie
noch die sd karte von denen geklaut
zerstören und die beiden irgendwie
geschubst oder fast geschlagen ich weiß
nicht ich war nicht dabei um das ganze
zum abschluss zu bringen
ich kann einerseits die aktion von
kuchen tv und seinem kumpel nicht
richtig nachvollziehen dass er auf die
bühne gerannt ist also ich weiß nicht
wie man auf so eine idee kommt ja immer
gesagt das war einfach witzig und für
ein video also ja weiß ich also ich
würde so etwas nicht machen auf der
anderen seite muss natürlich sagen
[ __ ] ist eine richtig krasse
beleidigung und man hätte danach auch
wirklich mit denen vernünftig reden
können mit denen sagen können und helau
helau später einfach die daten auf der
festplatte laden ist einfach nicht hoch
stattdessen sind dabei was er wohl
irgendwie emotionen durchgebrannt und er
ist ein bisschen ausgerastet wirklich
ich kann also nicht sagen ich war nicht
dabei ich war zu dem zeitpunkt auf klo
glaube ich solle durch westlich ich
kenne marcel ein wenig persönlich und
kuchen tv überhaupt nicht aber ich finde
jetzt im nachhinein muss ich wirklich zu
geben
ich will nicht dass ich hier für jetzt
gerettet werden oder sonst irgendwas die
statement videos von kuchen tv empfinde
ich als glaubwürdiger und besser weil er
mit quellen ankommt er macht das ganze
strukturierte er präsentiert seine
meinung einfach grundsätzlich besser ich
kenne marcel nur leicht persönlich
kuchen tv kenne ich eigentlich überhaupt
nicht abseits von seinem content der auf
youtube hochlädt ich muss ganz ehrlich
zugeben auch wenn max kran crafter der
so auf youtube wirklich so mein bester
kumpel ist wenn der brief mit einer
anderen person hätte würde ich auch
nicht nutzen max halten wenn er mein
kumpel ist sondern wird mir da auch
beide seiten einholen beide ansichten
und mich dann halt für die seite
entscheiden die ja einfach recht hat
aber wie gesagt ich will da überhaupt
keine stellung beziehen ich will nicht
sagen ich will auf kuchens sein ich bin
auf case krieg seit ich finde nur dass
das ganze irgendwie aufhören sollte weil
beide haben scheiße gebaut so ich finde
es nicht nötig dass man den auftritt von
anderen youtuber auf der bühne stören
muss und sich da irgendwie durch vögel
lassen muss auf der anderen seite finde
ich ein bisschen übertrieben wie marcel
da reagiert hat aber das sind beides
irgendwie blöde sachen und ich finde
diese beiden seiten sollten
auch sagen ok was blödes gemacht wir
leben jetzt wieder in frieden mehr oder
weniger aber so weit wird es glaube ich
nicht kommen ich wollte das nur sagen
weil da irgendwie jeder gerade drüber
redet und jeder irgendeine seite bezieht
und irgendwie irgendwie beleidigt in
jedem video deswegen freunde ich dir auf
keiner seite
das ist das ende von mir meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat wie ich
mich über die bewertung freund schreibt
man die kommentare was ich morgen oder
die tage hochladen soll ich habe hier so
ein galileo wie sich schwer papstes
schwer kings bau cup mit dem können was
machen aber das entscheidet ihr genau
sportclub